MONTREAL CANADIENS DID NOT
DVORAK. OFF HIS BODY, BUT
WATCH HIM T
THAT IS WHY HE WAS BROUGHT BACK
FROM THE KHL, TO RUN THAT SECOND
UNIT.
AND THEY'RE LITERALLY RIGHT ON
THE EDGE OF THE CREASELINE..
T A STICK ON IT.
THAT IS IN.
DEREKEN
AND ON A BREAK AWAY.
HEAD UP COMING
KULAKryan: SVECHNIKOV INTONDS LE
MAN-ADVANTAGE AS WE'RE UNDERWAY.
OH, WHAT A PASS.
AROUND.
ALL THE WAY ACROSS TO BACKDOOR.
THAT SHOT.
JAKE ALLEN KEEPS DROPPING ON THE
PLAY, BUT NO IS ANDERSON.
ANDERSON HE WAS RACING IN FOR
THE GLOVE OF FRED FRE. BY ROMAN.
UP FOR DVORAK.
THREE MINUTES 10 SECONDS TO GO
IN THE.
STAAL WILL DELAY.
THOUGHT A
SUZUKI.
SUZ WIDEMAN,
NICK S SAVARD, ROMANOV..
TOFFOLI.
CAUFIEL TOP.
LOADS UP SCORES! ALL OF IT. THED
MONTREAL WITH A LITTLE PUSHB
SAVARD.
SAVARD UP THE ICE.
JOHN TAVARES.
WITH SPACE.
HERE COMES DROUIN.
GREAT BACKHAND TRY.
STOPPED BY ANDERSEN.. GOODNESS,.
DVORAK WITH HIM.
DON VALLEY VORK FLIPS IT
AND SCORES.
THERE IS YOTREPIECE IS
NUMBER 20.
SE